[Music]
the storm could not have come at a worse
time for hospitals in louisiana with
icu's already overwhelmed with patience
from the latest coveted surge new
orleans is completely without power this
morning making an already tough
situation even more difficult for
doctors nurses and patients
we're joined now by dr mark klein
physician and chief at children's
hospital in new orleans dr klein good
morning
good morning can you bring us up to date
on exactly what the situation is at your
hospital
well we had a rough day um
we have a considerable amount of damage
to the hospital itself including to our
brand new building which is a 300
million dollar building that literally
opened
two days before the hurricane's landfall
we we've had intrusion of water under
the ground floor several inches of water
into our chapel which has not even been
used at this point
also
water through the roof
we have
issues with
electricity of course no electricity so
we're on emergency generation and have
been on that
emergency power for a little more than
12 hours
um
the good news is that all of our
patients stayed safe
we were locked down from about six
o'clock yesterday morning on we're still
locked down
so we've got a lot of staff that are in
the hospital either
literally not sleeping at all or
sleeping on air mattresses and they did
a great job taking care of the patients
and all the patients are safe but
going forward we're very concerned about
the power situation we're concerned
about clean water
and
we have a substantial number of
critically ill children in the hospital
and we're making contingency plans for
potentially transferring them to a
children's hospital in another state if
necessary
you've been operating on backup
generators thus far when do you expect
to get full power back are you like
everyone else
well we've been told is that the power
grid failure in new orleans was
cataclysmic and that we can expect to be
without power for a week or more
our sense is that
there really isn't a timetable for
restoration of power
we currently have
fuel for emergency generation
to last about another four days
and we don't know what our ability will
be to get additional fuel in given the
situations with the roads
without power you don't get clean water
in you don't have uh sufficient sewage
out
i'm just curious is there an evacuation
plan
that you were
looking at moving forward past those
four four days
yes so so we began the contingency
planning and scenario planning around
that last night we did most of that uh
overnight
and uh we'll be placing some calls to uh
a couple of other children's hospitals
today you know fewer than five percent
of all the hospitals nationally are
children's hospitals so we don't have
the luxury of being able to transfer
patients
to just any hospital because we really
take care of the sickest of the sick
children with very complex medical
problems and so
would have to be a facility that has
capabilities that are similar to ours
and
we cover a broad swath of the gulf south
we're very proud of the fact that we're
standing in the gap for children across
louisiana and the in the central gulf
south and
and if if we're put in a position of
having to do that
it will be a significant problem for
children and families across a several
hundred mile swath
of this part of the country
yeah so much of your staff has endured
so much in terms of their mental
emotional health we send them our best
dr mark klein thank you and thank you
for all that you do